question is this what is this hurting
who is it helping meaning this whole you
know celebrity fighting where anybody
can come out uh who's losing is this
good for dana is it bad is it piss and
dana off is it good for boxing is it bad
for boxing i think it's good for
everybody tell me what i think it's good
for everybody because i think you're
seeing guy a guy in jake paul who's
bringing
attention to fighter pay and uh showing
that he controls his own destiny he
literally it's his production he's you
know getting the benefits from all of it
so i think if ufc fighters are smart
they can take something and learn
something from that so it doesn't hurt
dana you're ufc can't be hurt dana's
brilliant so he can't be hurt but you
know dana anytime this competition he's
going to on it but i think it's
good for everybody boxing ufc just
brings attention to the combat special
do it all the other sports too like if i
were kyrie irving right now i'd be like
screw it i don't want to go back to the
nba a million dollars a game i'll put up
a million you put on you one thousand
play one on one on showtime i'll play 10
guys at night but if jake gets knocked
out by a diaz does that does this
stardom fade meaning like all right
everyone wants to see this kid get
knocked out you agree everybody wants to
see that sure right except for his
whatever 40 million subscribers
i think half of them want to see them i
don't think so right i think we live in
it we're older and we live on the social
media which isn't real man
it's not real regardless people would
like to see him get knocked out but when
he does
do you think that people will still pay
to see 100 yeah you think they'll still
keep going i think even when he loses
that there's going to be a rematch
clause in that fight he's going to make
money so america loves to come back he
set up well
look at logan paul's record he's what
0-2 yeah 0-2-1 0-2-1 and anybody here
people still want to watch his gut fight
well i think his upside is way bigger
than jake yeah he's got it
let me know oh you think disagree
disagree you think jake paul has bigger
upside than logan paul yeah because jake
paul wants an actual career in boxing
logan paul wants to fight the most
famous guys and make the most money
possible and get out he's talking beyond
fighting i'm not even saying the
president likes somebody oh you're
saying i'm saying bigger than fighting
oh yeah logan yeah have you have you
guys had him i'm surprised you haven't
interviewed him we haven't yet brilliant
guy yeah he seems like it's smart the
way he moves smart these it's not
accident like a lot of these guys it's
not an accident
even the vines back in the data were
hilarious to begin with
business wise monster and you gotta
appreciate the hustle you are you think
of yourself as an adrenaline junkie man
no not at all not at all so i mean
you've lived your whole adult life here
seeking bigger and bigger and bigger
spotlights i'm an adrenaline junkie 100
i don't know so and when it's quiet and
there's nobody around you're happy
you're not itching like man i gotta find
something to do i gotta do some crazy
here no i mean i i get restless
because i wanna because i feel like you
can always be working which is a problem
especially i have kids i have a five and
two year old so that can be a problem
where you're always thinking about work
but drilling junk you know like i never
jump out of plane and i don't drive
fast i have cool cars i don't drive fast
i can't i can't do two days really no
pat you have you ever driven fast no
i've had my license suspended a few
times yeah
what's the fastest you've ever driven
uh i just i'm this isn't a flex i just
got a new ferrari and i was going down
the the five in uh california driving
back from san diego yeah i got like 115.
115. 115. that's like a wednesday i
don't i don't drive i'm like he's an
adrenaline junkie i don't want it
that he doesn't drive an adrenaline
junkie that won't go in the car with him
i don't know you you you driving with
this guy we're in uh we're in a bentley
we weren't a bentley
it was the four-door was it the con was
it the moose you're asking me i got to
take an uber everywhere that was cool
though yeah it was uh
660 horsepower we're on what the 405 405
yes okay 405 l.a
during covet so it's like not that legit
just for the record it's a legend
he goes let's let's open this baby up
let's see what we got
dude
he it felt like we were going
60. yeah he goes you know how fast we
were just going right there 150.
oh wow he goes let's remix this
allegedly he hits it again
now i'm like paying attention
165. on the 405. yes there's a place to
do it though we were going to when it's
six months
coveted cops aren't even that's right
that was insanity screw that rush hour
dallas allegedly we're going to miss out
we're going to imagine
the flight takes off at an hour and 15.
from the old office oh my gosh i forgot
the old office to the airport to dfw was
about 45. like they started boarding by
the time that we got in the car we made
the flight wow good for you i've never
seen anything like that i went to go be
a cop when i got out of the military i'm
like this is a good right you know
military you get out you were in a
marine so when you get out you're
thinking you get additional points to be
a firefighter or a cop right i go to be
a cop i take the test and uh they said
you can't be a cop i said why can't i be
a cop i was 21 years old with 16
speeding tickets that's not going to
happen i said you realize i'm going to
catch the bad guy better than anybody
else
so you got you got comedy big
personality huge body athlete college
athlete wwe it's like first ballot hall
of fame wwe what happened here man no
way man no uh with the podcasting i have
my thick boy network so we do a you know
i bought my own studio i run everything
either hide my own staff i get sick boy
merch i'm talking like 10 years ago 15
years ago
no no no no i don't know what a vintage
[Music]
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]